noël nous invitant quatre invités
exceptionnels le présentateur phare du
20 heures
la rock star du stand up l'habite ont
préféré des français
la mascotte de l'équipe de france
moi c'est geronimo forme après jérôme
roux ne pas taper du tout mais on s'en
fout
allez venez regarder la chose qu'on a
la nature nous souhaitons la bienvenue
[Musique]
évidemment nous invite escompte un
patient en patient montcourt bienvenue
les amis chez les bâlois pour cette
enfance au bout du bout du gouffre
garder comme la pokémon je vais taper le
chef comme tout le monde ça sera
beaucoup plus simple c'est les photos
qui les intéressent
il n'est plus qu' il faut du voodoo avec
abane en n'omettant renvoyé à deux
reprises et s'est dit qu il convenait
nocturne chez les papouilles
l'ag comment il a pu en dégage du script
pourtant derrière l'union for her pourra
jouer
rokita
ce sont pas des gens normaux comme vous
et moi ce sont des gens célèbres et j'ai
testé tout le monde c'est normal
en fait le plus gros fléau de l'afrique
c'est vous pardon
alors on reste encore parce que j'ai pas
de solution pour être la mienne et il
est complètement con lui